foreign
hey everyone it's marcus brownlee and
welcome to another hd tutorial and in
this video i'll be showing you the easy
way um that i use to make call outs in
camtasia studio six so i'll be going
over a number of the camtasia studio six
features here but first of all i'm going
to open up camtasia studio and this is
the interface itself here we go um in
order to add a callout first of all you
need to have some media here so i'm just
going to enter
drag in two clips here just to ensure
videos that i've done nothing special
and i'm going to take them and drag them
onto the timeline drag them down here
they'll be added now you're going to
have to choose a preset and i do upload
all my videos in hd so if you want to
know how exactly i get my hd preset go
ahead and watch that video so i'm going
to hit ok and these two clips are
officially on the timeline and i can go
and preview them and edit them at my
will
now if i'm
if i come to a certain point where i
want to add an annotation or sorry a
call out which is basically the camtasia
studio 6 version of an annotation we're
going to do is go over here to the edit
button and go over and hit the
sorry go over and hit the callouts
button
and the callouts button is basically um
the callouts are basically a little uh
text boxes or different things that you
can put over a video uh they won't slant
with your video but they'll they'll work
very very well and make your video look
professional and you have very good
video editing so um first of all you
have to choose the type of annotation
and there are trust me a lot of types of
annotations that you can add here
first of all there's arrow and you will
always see by the way the annotation
that you're doing in the top on in the
preview window so you can see you
editing your own call out here adjust
the dimensions of it
and you can always put text in it so you
could say
look
uh look i can't type today look here so
there it'll show up in your preview
window live as you type it
so what i like to do um you can also do
i'll just go through these a two-sided
arrow just basically looks like that an
hour on both sides an indented arrow a
blur call out can be used for like
blurring personal information so if i
don't want you to see something you can
put several layers of a blur call out on
top of something you don't want to see i
do use that uh occasionally in my
tutorials but no big deal
next i'll show you it the highlighter
callout
is actually what you can use to
highlight text now won't work very well
with this
with this particular clip here because
there's no text in it but if i was doing
the screencast and i didn't want to use
an arrow or a spotlight which i'll show
you in a second then i'll use a little
a little yellow highlighter just to show
you guys the exact text i want to show
you
so next oh and you can also choose the
fill color of the highlighter next you
can choose a highlight rectangle which
doesn't do much it just kind of
brightens the uh brightens what you have
there you can change the color obviously
the fill color of a lot of these
different highlighters and just hit ok
to actually change it
now we're going to keep going down to a
transparent hotspot i never really use
because it doesn't work in youtube okay
this just works for powerpoint
presentations so if you want to see the
powerpoint presentations video go ahead
and look at that there's a little
integration with camtasia studio 6 and
powerpoints you can do a notepad one
which basically looks like this
i have used this once in a while
pardon me i have used this once in a
while you can choose which side the note
tab is on um
not a very big deal um you can change
the obviously the fill color and the
opacity of it
and i do use these all pretty much all
these callouts once a while and i'll
show you samples obviously as i go
through these here next is a bubble call
out
a square call out which is uh i think i
believe transparent then the spotlight
call out which i do use kind of often it
grays out everything in the photo except
for what you put
the spotlight over so if i want to
spotlight a certain thing i just drag it
and i hit the finish button and it is uh
it is actually spotlighting it for that
particular length on the timeline
uh let's keep going down here you can
have a filled rectangle a rounded
rectangle a little speech bubble
rectangle and a text call out now the
text callout is what i use the most it's
just a simple text overlay uh you can
obviously change the font here i'll
change it to calibri my favorite font
and change the size it'll be a little
bigger and there you see
on the uh in the preview window it says
look here and there's the text so um i
do use these callouts quite a bit in my
videos i know you guys have asked so
there you go that's how you use the text
callout now custom callouts this is
really fun um
you can add or edit a custom callout now
i'm going to remove these custom
callouts but um basically if i want to
show you guys say a picture of something
i would go onto the internet and find a
picture and use that as a custom
call-out or maybe just a screenshot so
let's go ahead and open up the snip tool
in windows vista and uh just take a
little uh snip of what we want to show
everyone in our video we want to show
everyone this little uh time this little
uh toolbar up here i'm just going to
snip that and there is my file i'm going
to hit save and i'm going to save it as
a callout
file
in
my picture so it's my pictures call out
file save it
and you can just exit out of this it's a
jpeg image so now when we say we want a
custom callout we're going to go to
add slash edit custom
and again remove these customs and we're
going to select new custom callout which
is where we actually go into our
pictures here and whether we've saved
one from the internet or we've created a
screenshot or whatever we're going to
find that picture
and here is the callout file and i'll
just hit open
and here it is in the preview window
that's exactly what we're looking for
you can change the dimensions but you
can also obviously do that in a preview
window
so i'm just going to hit ok
and then we're going to actually have to
select it so just go to select that
custom callout and there it is now
there's still text overlay so i'll just
delete that text
and here is what we wanted to show
people there it is we can obviously um
we can make it bigger so people can see
it better we can make it smaller so
people don't uh it doesn't draw too much
attention but what i like to do um if i
hit finish here and i go to zoom and pan
i like to tilt the video to one side
and have the call out on the other side
so i tilted the video to that side i'll
have a call out drag it over here to the
other side it's an extreme example it
doesn't obviously fit very well but
that's that's what i like to do
so yeah that's how i add call outs you
can obviously add text to any uh to any
call out you'd like um it does you can
change the font i obviously showed you
guys where to get fonts anywhere you
like
and uh down in the timeline you can
obviously change how long the call-out
lasts so if it's a spotlight and you
happen to zoom away you don't have to um
you don't have to have the spotlight
still on while you zoomed away from what
you wanted to highlight so that's very
good
uh so yeah that's basically the general
introduction of call-outs in camtasia
studio six um i will have a lot more
camtasia studio six uh what's it called
tutorials coming out sorry um whether it
has to do with audio with video editing
and i'm trying to make a music video so
i can show you guys a very interesting
music video but anyway that is how you
do callouts at camtasia studio 6. i hope
you found this video helpful and if you
do have any other video tutorials or
requests just pm me or send me a message
and if you are subscribed i'll do a
request video i'll show you guys exactly
how i do this kind of stuff and i'll put
your link in the description so people
can check out your channel so thanks for
watching this video subscribe for more
and i hope you like this tutorial and
all the rest to come so thanks for
watching peace